[Music]
Rhonda Hesse loves boxers she already
has a senior one named Smalls but this
summer she decided to add mini to the
pack she was just the sweetest thing she
was so cuddly and Squishy after taking
Minnie to the vet she found out Minnie
was pregnant with six puppies and I've
never had a dog before that was pregnant
Weeks Later Minnie had to have an
emergency C-section at the vet just when
Minnie was adjusting to Motherhood at
home three of the puppies died and days
later she started hemorrhaging and
needed emergency help but with many
weighing over 80 pounds there was no way
hessie could get her in the car alone so
she called to the Henderson Fire
Department she called us we're gonna go
and help we'll see the best we can fire
fire paramedic Jason law says it's a
call he and his team never had to
respond to before we are in all
emergency department and this was truly
an emergency it wasn't a human emergency
but this was an emergency so when I
picked her up she kind of just flopped
into my arms and I knew that
you know she was really sick I said just
hold on baby your mom is going to take
you to the vet and I kissed her on the
head and closed the door Minnie died
before arriving at the Animal Hospital
leaving her puppies now without a mom
and say goodbye and sorry
so then you know just came home and then
all of a sudden I had these three
puppies I had to take care of three
puppies that now had to be bottle fed
three times a day back at the fire
station law wasn't able to get Minnie or
hessy out of his mind I called dispatch
and I said I need that callback number
I need to I need to contact so I text I
said I know this is really weird and I
don't I've never done this before but I
feel that connection with you and if you
need help my daughters can come over and
help you because we had an experience
like this we know how to
um feed puppies but feeding puppies
quickly turned into wanting to take one
home that little girl has got me wrapped
around her paw as soon as Minnie's
puppies were old enough they were
adopted by a vet tech and the law family
and although hessie wasn't planning on
raising a puppy she decided she needed
to keep a part of Minnie and her home
there's times where
um you know they're just being spicy or
whatever and I can just picture her just
kind of like putting him in place
although this story started with sadness
firefighter and paramedic Jason says it
was a true reminder that no call is ever
too small or too big Victoria Saha eight
news now